For those of you that do know me,
I recently secured two committee roles on society.
One being creative vice director
of women in trading at NOT
and the second one being a vice president of
Impact Consulting,
which is a student LED consulting firm at Uni.
We basically do consulting for
socially driven organisations around and across the UK.
Um, and just helping them with their problems.
That's really cool.
When applications open and you go to Knott's,
be applying
cause they open in spring. Anyway,
um, I didn't secure any leadership experience
when I was in my first and second year.
And literally
one of my TikTok posts
I was like oh my God,
you know what?
Like I can't believe
I haven't secured any leadership experience.
Like no way
it's another.
And it's actually not,
especially if you're in your third year.
So the whole purpose of this video
is kinda just going through the steps you can take
to secure committee or leadership experience
force that you need,
especially if you didn't do it in your first and second,
which is a lot of people,
especially cause of COVID.
So first, I know this sounds really bad,
but be making friends with the right people.
And I when I say this, I mean
make friends with people who are equally driven as you.
If you're interested in consulting,
make friends with people who had springs in consulting.
Don't do it intentionally.
Like, don't do it like
I don't know how to explain. Like,
don't be a beg about it.
If someone doesn't feel your vibe,
still don't like,
feel obliged to be friends with them
just cause they're interested in concern,
but just be making friends with people
that match your vibe
and match your goals as well.
Um, they don't.
All your friends don't have to match your goal.
But I'm saying
if you want opportunities,
you just have to know the right people
because you need to have people in your life
that can vouch for you.
Especially in terms of like,
committee positions,
cause there's a lot of that type of stuff that you.
The second one.
If you're passionate about something,
the best thing that you can ever do
is make a business out of it.
Make a business out of it.
If you can do hair,
do a hair business.
If you can do lashes,
do a lash business.
I've been so impressed by the set.
Like, some CVS that I've seen,
whether it's reviewing my C.
Reviewing people CVS, um,
where they have a business
and they're milking it
because, as you should, business.
Having a business,
being a business owner
is the best type of experience you can have.
And I cannot stress this enough.
Even like, content creation
doesn't have to be
like a business,
but it can be.
Like if you own a TikTok page
and you're helping people,
that is technically
like a business job.
And Especially if you brand it and everything.
It's amazing
if you wanna be like
a creative vice director or um,
publicity officer
or welfare officer
because you can get information out there and assist.
My third and final point would be
if you're looking at like,
don't just join any society,
don't just run any society
if you're not passionate about it.
But say you're passionate about finance,
be engaging with these finance societies,
be applying to their divisions,
cause for example
they have divisions at. Not um,
be applying for that
but also just be engaging with the people
so then they know who you are.
And when you apply for the like,
I don't know,
well, for office of the following year,
they can say, oh,
I know this person
and this person does this.
People, in their eyes
are more likely to want someone that they know
take over their roles
than someone that they don't know.
So be network.
And you know what?
Also add if you feel like there's a gap in the society,
make your own cause
that demonstrates initiative,
drive and real life leadership.
But yeah, follow for more.
Let me know what you wanna see next.